Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想先简单向大家介绍一件现在正在进行的激动人心的事。如果你曾经好奇如何创造为你源源不断带来收入的模式，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）——我的商业导师——带来的“向持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Group interviews can be so tricky.
这些原则对你同样适用。本次活动还将有由丽莎本人直接送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特ント（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士一对一一小时的辅导。你想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详细信息发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。群面可能会非常棘手。
It's easy to either get lost in the crowd or to risk coming across as too pushy. In this episode, I will teach you how to find the perfect balance to leave a lasting impression. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne. Thank you so much for being here. Group interviews have cropped up at all stages of my life and career. The first being when I was being interviewed for a part-time job with Boots the chemist. And I remember at the time thinking, how am I going to stand out? How are they going to get a sense of me? How am I going to stand out? How are they going to get a sense of me? How am I going to, you know, form a good enough relationship with the people on the panel to be able to stand out but not be
人们很容易要么在人群中默默无闻，要么显得过于强势。在本期节目中，我将教你如何找到完美的平衡点，从而留下持久的印象。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士。非常感谢你能来到这里。群面贯穿了我生活和职业生涯的所有阶段。第一次是在我面试博茨药妆店（Boots the chemist）的兼职工作时。我记得当时在想，我该如何脱颖而出？他们将如何了解我？我该如何脱颖而出？他们将如何了解我？我该如何，你知道的，与评委小组的人建立足够好的关系，从而脱颖而出，但又不会
not be too much? And this has continued, you know, they can crop up in assistant psychologist posts, they can crop up as part of doctorate interviews. They might well crop up as kind of reflective group exercises. These might just crop up where you least expect them. So having some strategies up your sleeve can be a really good piece of your interview preparation kit. So let's dive in. Let's go through our first of my top tips. So before we get stuck in, let's have a think about why group interviews are used and what the functions of those are. Organizations use these to kind of look at some of the soft skills, to look at how candidates operate in teams, to get a sense of what their communication styles are like,
表现得过头？这种情况一直在延续，你知道的，它们可能会出现在助理心理学家的岗位上，也可能作为博士面试的一部分。它们很可能以反思性小组练习的形式出现。这些情况可能会在你最意想不到的时候突然出现。因此，胸有成竹地准备一些策略，可以成为你面试准备工具包中的宝贵财富。让我们深入探讨吧。让我们来看看我的首要建议中的第一条。在我们深入探讨之前，让我们先思考一下为什么会使用群面以及这些面试的功能是什么。组织使用这些面试来考察一些软技能，观察候选人在团队中的运作方式，了解他们的沟通风格，
and also to think about how problem solving happens when you are around. Some common ways that these group interviews will crop up might be role play to kind of think about an assessment or perhaps a tricky or challenging situation that crops up that you might not be expecting. There might be a group discussion on an ethical dilemma or something that kind of might get people a little bit hot under the collar. Or perhaps it could be, you know, a real kind of life practical task that might crop up in the service or in the role that you are applying for, which might be, you know, decisions on risk, it might be thinking about who to offer an initial assessment appointment to, based on kind of suitability of referrals. And in all of these tasks, it's of course important to have
还要思考当你在场时问题是如何解决的。群面中常见的一些形式可能是角色扮演，用来考察某种评估，或者可能是你可能没有预料到的棘手或具有挑战性的情况。可能会有一个关于道德困境的小组讨论，或者可能会让人感到有点压力的事情。或者这可能是一个真实的、生活中的实际任务，可能会在你申请的服务或职位中出现，这可能是风险决策，可能是根据转诊的适宜性思考将初次评估预约提供给谁。在所有这些任务中，当然重要的是要发挥
an individual part to play. But it's also worth thinking about what role you might play within that group and whether you always need to be the shining star. So let's have a think about some top tips to try and stand out in all of the right ways. Of course what we know in any interview situation but also specifically if this is a mental health field interview, is that we are going to need to highlight our skills as an active listener. That might include kind of summarising, it might include building upon other ideas that you've heard, of course in a way that doesn't just paraphrase exactly what someone said and trying to kind of put it out there as your brand new idea. So you
你个人的作用。但同样值得思考的是，你可能在该小组中扮演什么角色，以及你是否总是需要成为那颗耀眼的明星。因此，让我们思考一些能够以正确的方式脱颖而出的顶级建议。当然，我们在任何面试情况中都知道，特别是如果这是一场心理健康领域的面试，我们需要突显我们作为积极倾听者的技能。这可能包括总结，可能包括建立在你听到的其他想法之上，当然，这种方式不能仅仅是鹦鹉学舌般重复别人说过的话，然后试图把它当作你全新的想法。所以你
might want to say something like, that's a really great point, thank you. And I think this might add quite nicely to it. Another really important skill to have is about how to show leadership without dominating a conversation or being oppressive. If you spot that somebody seems to be quieter or struggling to get a word in, it might be an opportunity to say, you know, I wonder what you thought about this. And of course, we want to be offering our clear suggestions without shutting other people down in a way that might be deemed confrontational or rude, or that you're just not tuned in to the process. Our communication always needs to be as clear as possible, of course. We want to be not too wordy, but not too succinct either. It's that Goldilocks, three bears, porridge and chairs and beds being just the right size. So we're trying
可能会想说：“这是一个非常棒的观点，谢谢。我认为这可以很好地补充这一点。”另一个非常重要的技能是如何在不主导对话或表现得专制的情况下展现领导力。如果你发现有人比较安静或难以插话，这可能是一个机会，可以说：“你知道的，我想知道你对此有什么看法。”当然，我们希望在不以被视为对抗性、粗鲁或与流程脱节的方式贬低他人的前提下，提出我们清晰的建议。我们的沟通当然需要尽可能清晰。我们希望既不要啰嗦，也不要过于简练。就像金发姑娘和三只熊的故事里，粥、椅子和床的尺寸都要刚刚好。所以我们在努力
to be concise and confident, but also engaging. If we are using any abbreviations, for example, things like CBT, then it's always good practice to try to use them fully at first before shortening them to the abbreviated form. And similarly, try to avoid using any jargon where possible, because people might not always understand exactly what you mean. And it's part of our clear and concise strategy that we want everybody to understand exactly what you're saying first time around. Like I said, we're going to want to be engaging, but we're also going to want to be authentic. We don't want to make it look as if we're playing a role, putting a mask on. It's supposed to feel like a bit of you and it's supposed to feel comfortable to be around you. And a way of doing that is to try to think about how can I
做到简明自信，同时引人入胜。如果我们使用了任何缩写，例如 CBT（认知行为疗法），那么在缩写之前先完整说出全称，通常是很好的做法。同样，尽可能避免使用任何行话，因为人们可能并不总是完全理解你的意思。作为我们清晰简练策略的一部分，我们希望每个人都能在第一时间准确理解你所说的话。正如我所说，我们希望引人入胜，但也希望保持真实。我们不想让人觉得我们在扮演某个角色，戴着面具。它应该带有一点你的特色，并且让人觉得和你在一起很舒服。做到这一点的方法之一是思考我如何能够
collaborate best in this setting rather than thinking about how can I win? How can I be the champion? How can I be the ruler in this setting? So thinking about collaboration rather than coming in and stealing the prize can be a really good way to think about this. Before the interview can be a really good idea to think about your own unique strengths and talents. If you're naturally empathic or really good at analytical thinking or juggling complex ideas, then have those in mind and try to think about opportunities where you can showcase those talents. And one of the biggest top tips is try to avoid the
在这种环境中进行最佳合作，而不是去想我如何才能赢？我如何成为冠军？我如何成为这里的统治者？因此，考虑合作而不是带着掠夺的心态去争夺奖项，是思考这个问题的绝佳方式。在面试前，花时间思考自己独特的优势和才能是一个非常棒的主意。如果你天生富有同理心、擅长分析思考或能够应对复杂的想法，那么请将这些铭记在心，并寻找能够展示这些才能的机会。其中一个最重要的建议是尽量避免
comparisonitis. Try not to think about everybody else in the group interview setting as being your competition. You know, I think especially for jobs where multiple roles are being offered, it's possible that maybe all of you in that setting, in that interview are going to be or could be offered a role. So try not to think about having to trip people over and, you know, get to the finish line before them, because actually we're wanting to elevate ourselves, but in a way that is compassionate and that makes us look like a great team player because we are of course. So try to focus on your contribution, how you can contribute rather than necessarily trying to outperform the people that you're in
比较情结（comparisonitis）。尽量不要把群面环境中的每个人都视为你的竞争对手。你知道的，特别是对于提供多个岗位的职位，很有可能在那种环境中、在那个面试中，你们所有人都会或者都可能被录用。所以尽量不要想着必须把别人绊倒，你知道的，赶在他们之前冲过终点线，因为实际上我们希望提升自己，但这种提升是以富有同情心的方式进行的，并且让我们看起来像一个优秀的团队合作者，因为我们本来就是。因此，请专注于你的贡献，思考你如何能够做出贡献，而不必刻意去表现得比你在面试中
the interview with. Like any interviews of course it's understandable that you might be feeling quite nervous. We need to make sure that we are hitting the sweet spot so that we are getting the best performance possible from ourselves without kind of tipping into our hyper aroused state or dipping down into our hypo aroused state, because neither of those things are going to help us to thrive and to shine. So in order to manage those nerves, a little bit of preparation might be helpful for whatever job interview you've got. It might be helpful to do a bit of a Google search for that job title and to Google it in
同组的人更优秀。就像任何面试一样，你感到紧张是完全可以理解的。我们需要确保自己达到最佳状态，以便发挥出最佳水平，而不会陷入过度觉醒（hyper-aroused）状态，或者跌入低度觉醒（hypo-aroused）状态，因为这两种状态都无助于我们蓬勃发展和闪耀光芒。为了控制这些紧张情绪，对于你面临的任何工作面试，做一点准备可能会有所帮助。在谷歌上搜索该职位头衔，并结合
combination with common group activity questions or tasks. You might also find it helpful to practice your active listening skills and to try to be as concise as possible. I remember when I was in secondary school, we had to kind of paraphrase kind of chunks of text, and that might be a really nice way of helping you to kind of weed out the great quality stuff that you need to be able to say so that it's not just getting lost in content. If you are feeling nervous, of course, just take a moment, take a breath and try to reframe that it's not just getting lost in content. If you are feeling nervous, of course, just take a moment, take a breath and try to reframe that as excitement for how much you want this job so that we can aim to stay within your zone of brilliance. So yes, group interviews are
常见的群面问题或任务进行搜索，可能会对你有所帮助。你可能还会发现，练习积极倾听的技能并尽量做到简明扼要对你很有帮助。我记得上中学时，我们需要对大段文本进行释义（paraphrase），这可能是一个非常好的方法，能帮你筛选出你需要表达的高质量内容，而不至于迷失在冗长的信息中。如果你感到紧张，当然，只需花一点时间，深呼吸，然后尝试重新构思——这并不是迷失在内容中，而是将这种紧张转化为你对这份工作的渴望，从而让我们能够保持在你高光表现的区间内。所以，是的，群面
not about competition. They are about collaboration and helping yourself and everybody else in there to shine. I would love to know your top tips for this. Which one of these has resonated with you best? Please do subscribe. Please do like. Please do drop a comment. How do you prepare for your interviews? How can you begin to tap into feeling grounded, to feeling like you can lift your head high, be yourself and know that that's enough. And of course, like any good interview, regardless of the outcome, it can create a really nice opportunity for reflection and for jotting down in your journal afterwards, which bits felt most comfortable for you, which bits felt like you perhaps needed to work on a little bit more. And whatever the outcome, it's OK to ask the people for feedback about your performance.
不是关于竞争。它们关乎合作，关乎帮助你自己和那里的每个人闪耀光芒。我很想知道你在这方面的顶级建议。其中哪一条对你的触动最大？请务必订阅。请务必点赞。请务必留下评论。你是如何为面试做准备的？你如何开始融入一种脚踏实地的感觉，感觉自己可以昂首挺胸，做自己，并知道这就足够了。当然，就像任何优秀的面试一样，无论结果如何，它都能为反思创造一个非常好的机会，让你在事后在日记中记下哪些部分让你感到最舒适，哪些部分觉得可能还需要做更多的努力。无论结果如何，向他人征求对你表现的反馈是完全可以接受的。
If you are an aspiring psychologist and you would welcome some support to help you prepare for interviews, either group or individual, please do consider checking out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. We do really lovely things in there, which covers all sorts of things from CBT, interview skills, application skills, research, as well as specialist approaches and clinical areas. Please also do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner.
如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，并且希望获得一些支持来帮助你准备面试（无论是群面还是个面），请考虑了解“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership），你只需每月 30 英镑即可加入，且无最低期限要求。我们在里面做很多非常棒的事情，涵盖了从 CBT、面试技能、申请技能、研究到专业方法和临床领域的各种内容。请务必查看《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective book）、《临床心理学家集体》一书，以及玛丽安·特ント博士主持的《临床心理学家集体播客》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective Podcast）。我叫加娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现其中所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。达到这个目标竟然有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊叹，成为临床心理学家并没有唯一完美的方式，这让我充满了信心，让我觉得自己并没有做错，并减轻了自己的压力。因此，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但请相信我，一旦你开始阅读，你就不会把书放下。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。